hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor and in this video
i'm going to be answering
your property investment questions so
if you've got any property questions at
all around
tax mortgages investment areas lease
option agreements hmos
comment them below and i'm going to be
using my experience over the last 12
years
doing over 300 property deals to answer
your questions now do me a massive favor
and
smash the like button also subscribe
turn the notification out on otherwise
is what might happen i might answer your
question
but you didn't even see my answer
because you weren't subscribed so
comment your questions below subscribe
and i'll be answering as many questions
as i possibly can
next week on sunday next q a sunday so
last week we had greg
connolly say hi samuel a couple
questions one
when doing the brr strategy how do you
know that
what you're doing will add value to the
property i.e new kitchens bathrooms
general refurb maybe increase
epc is there a general guide great
question greg i'll answer that one first
so
um you are correct sometimes you can
spend money on a property
and you're not actually adding much
value i've got a cousin who spent i
think he was about a hundred thousand
pounds getting a really fancy
conservatory
and he's not added that much value to
the house
probably considerably less than the
money he spent so the general rule of
thumb
is every time you spend a pound you want
to be adding three pound
value to the property how do you know if
you're going to be doing that
well it depends on many different
factors it depends on the area
it depends on like for example
if you buy a property that's not got hot
water in it it might be unmortgageable
because a hot property that hasn't got
any hot water
you can't get a mortgage on it it's a
very easy problem to fix maybe you just
need a new boiler
but that's going to add tremendous value
because suddenly the property becomes
mortgageable again and how do you find
or if you've got a property that's got
um no kitchen or bathroom or if it's got
japanese knotweed it's very simple it's
just a case of saying
okay how much can you buy the property
for in its current state
and then you need to know how much is it
gonna be worth once you've done it up
and you're gonna
find out from valuers maybe speak to
estate agents
look at like for like sold comparison
properties and then you're going to
calculate what if i do the work
is it going to actually add as much
value as i think so i hope that helps
again there's no strict formula it's a
case of every single property deal is
very very different i hope that helps
you you had a second question which says
do you think when building a portfolio
of properties it's better to mortgage
on an interest-only basis for as long as
possible yes i do
interest only mortgage is the best in my
opinion because it gives you more cash
flow
you can then use that cash flow to buy
more properties which is going to give
you a bigger property portfolio which is
going to mean you're gaining from more
capital appreciation and getting more
cash flow as you build your portfolio so
yeah i would always do that and if you
want to pay the mortgage off pay the
mortgage down
but if you want a repayment mortgage you
have to pay the mortgage down rather
than you being in control
okay diana danila says
many thanks for these videos i feel
energetic motivated and individual
spirit after watching these are you so
welcome thanks for watching the channel
um in fact i sometimes watch them for
this purpose i'm about
the place and offer tomorrow and feeling
quite
terrified even though it's not my first
property it's a three bed house i want
to convert to a five bed hmo
it has a large kitchen diner so i could
convert both receptions i really wonder
if i'm doing the right thing
since it will not have a separate living
room so
diana if you've got no separate living
room if there's no communal area
and you want it to be a hmo that's okay
as long as the hmo rooms are 100 square
feet because if they're less than 100
square feet you will need a communal
area
uh that is generally the rule across the
uk
you may want to check with your local
council in terms of what the rules are
but what i'll say is
i know you're a little bit terrified
maybe because you're moving to a
different type of property or you're
moving bigger but hey if you're not
growing you're dying and the only way to
grow is to get out of your comfort zone
so congratulations on stepping out
and i wish you all the best on your next
property purchase need any help give us
a shout
jonathan cavall hi samuel i'm 16 years
old i'm interested in property investing
in the uk in the future but i live
outside of the uk
do and do not have a citizenship or
residency is that a problem for someone
outside of the uk to come and invest in
property
how can i do it will there be any
problem of getting a mortgage uh
jonathan so firstly you won't be able to
get a mortgage
because you're 16 not because you're
outside of the uk
um my advice would generally be
to start off in your hometown if you can
or your home country
just because i am from the middle of
england and have got built up my
portfolio in the mid
in birmingham uh doesn't necessarily
mean that that's what you need to do
because property investing real estate i
mean jesus investors all over the world
like some of my mentors are from the
states in america so
i wouldn't necessarily think you have to
invest in britain
i would to start with look at your home
country and
see how you can apply the principles
there because a lot of the stuff that i
teach and a lot of stuff that i do
can actually i'd say at least 90 percent
of it can be applied
in most developed countries um
so in terms of getting a mortgage it
might be that you want to get a mortgage
host
a guarantor or somebody but right now i
just decided on your area your patch and
your strategies
good job hope that helps okay dad says
hey samuel thanks for the videos
it really is appreciated you are so
welcome if you appreciate the videos
please let me know
by smashing the like button and also let
me know your questions
because without questions i can't make
videos so comment your questions below
that'd be really cool
i'm desperate to make a start in
property but i'm too risk-averse with
having a residential mortgage and three
children support
my wife isn't on our mortgage so we're
considering all the different strategies
in particular b-r-r-r
i'm looking at releasing some equity
from our house to enable my wife
to get a bridging loan and then a buy to
let mortgage hopefully interest only
what are your thoughts what are the
chances of her getting a buy to let
mortgage and a bridging loan and she's
never had a mortgage in her name any
interest only hard to obtain much
appreciated
um dad my brother i'm saying dad he's
not my dad that's just his name
on his channel dad so just to clear that
up
um firstly being risk averse
is not a bad thing as long as
you are not stupid about being risk
averse
like some people won't make decisions
because they're scared that something
could go wrong but here's the reality
the reality is you could you could not
leave your house
because you're scared you're gonna get
run over by a car you could not drive
because there's a lot of accidents
you could literally do nothing because
you're scared of making a mistake but
then i guess the
alternative to that is then just having
a terrible
miserable existence of not doing
anything so
my advice would be to take action and
yeah your
your idea is very plausible um
just make sure you look at the best case
in the worst case and don't take a risk
that's not a calculated risk where the
worst case could financially [ __ ] you
your wife should be able to get a
mortgage unless she's got really bad
credit or anything because if you're
looking at getting a buy to let
um or bridging specifically they care
more about the house than they do about
you
so i imagine that she will be able to
and if not you could always do it
together
she could apply but you could come on
and you could do it together so
um i think i would i would i would
really really really
um seek an education
uh if you haven't already take action
but
calculated action um and live the best
life you can so i hope that helps
great job and i hope to see you winning
always donable says hi i've purchased my
first bite property for two thousand
pound cheaper than the previous owner
did 12 years ago
is it common trend to see these rises
after a period of stagnation yeah it is
uh i don't know where the area is i
would imagine that the area
is probably up north and listen if 12
years ago the property was sold for more
expensive
you've just bought it now if it's cash
flowing positive amazing
it's probably going to go up in value
because it's bottomed out property
prices go up down
up down up down and every town has its
own economy so
yeah i would imagine in the next 12
years it'll go up significantly that'll
be my prediction
okay um muywa says
hi samuel i hope you're in the family a
while i was hoping you could help with
two questions i have
what are the exact steps needed to set
up a property business including all the
necessary insurances
and my second question is what are the
steps to becoming a deal source
including how much it will cost and to
become compliant
um well you are i don't know if i'm
pronouncing your name right but
what i would say is don't get focused on
the minor detail
when it comes to doing things like deal
sourcing and a property business
i tell you what you need you need deals
you need property deals you need
skills you need investors
you need people to know who you are you
need knowledge
you need to step out and take action you
need courage
more than you need
insurance and and the limited company
with the correct sick code i mean
do you know they don't even really care
about so many people get the sick code
wrong on companies and set it up wrong
the the the uh the hmrc don't even
really take into account
even if you do it's just like whatever
because so many people do wrong
you know so many people are worried to
do it right and they do it wrong anyway
you know spent ages doing their logo on
their business
card and i wouldn't worry look to become
compliant as a deal saucer
um it's gonna cost you about a thousand
pounds or so
okay um the insurance is that you need
depends on what your property business
is it depends on what it's doing if
you're just buying a house to rent out
you're gonna need
um you know you're gonna need property
insurance like landlord insurance
but i wouldn't worry about that i'd
worry about getting deals
i'd worry about getting good
enz frizzy thanks for answering my
question i'm making it all in the
video title the case study pack idea was
just what i needed
oh thank you so much i don't actually
remember what that what that means but
i'm glad it helped
hugo b hugo b hi sang i need some advice
hugo b sounds a bit like hugo boss
i hope this isn't joe license in
disguise
um i came across your videos earlier
this year and i knew property was the
path i would
take but as there are so many ways to
get into property i'm confusing which
path to take
rent to rent rent to sa lease options or
brr
knowing not knowing what path to take
has left me in the gutter
and i'm sure other people have this
problem so please can you give me some
advice i have 50 000 pounds
you know you're not really on the go if
you've got 50 000 pounds but okay
um would you start brr or rent to rent
the reason i'm not sure
um i don't want to take risks i'm really
careful okay okay
okay um hugo b
look you got 50 000 pounds and you're
saying
you're stuck maybe you're in the
paralysis
by analysis you know because you you're
talking about all these different
strategies
should i do rental rent should i do
these options brr should i do hmm should
i do
and you like and and you're doing
nothing
and you're right doing nothing will lead
to you ultimately being in the gutter so
my advice would be you know to just
choose one
and focus on it for three months and go
do that
just one even if it's the wrong strategy
at least at least at least you're just
taking action and doing something um
let's say if you chase
two rabbits you're catching on so just
pick one strategy
and just go for it and get get a
freaking deal you know
um that's my advice phil carr hi samuel
great content as always
i thought i had everything planned
refinanced my residential properties i
have 150 000
equity in a 300 000 pound property
75 loan to value plus savings would have
a starting part of about 150 000 pounds
i was going to just implement brr but
but since reading up on service
accommodation and the tax advantages on
torn any chance of a coffee
to run my ideas by you blown brain
same story phil you're like you're like
the last guy oh do i do this or do i do
this oh i'm not sure what to do
um and yeah of course you want to plan
it and you want to do it right
um for sure you want to sit and have a
coffee um
listen i'm sure you're a great guy and
we'll happily speak with you you know
what if you join
samuel 365 we can sure me and myself or
one of my team will jump on a call with
you
and we'll strategize the best strategy
for you for sure
and to be honest it will cost you less
than buying a freaking coffee for me
because it costs a pound to join samuel
365
for the first week and then it's 95
pound a month so pay up instead of
buying me a coffee
pay a pound to my training company jump
on a call with somebody strategize
and then after a week you can cancel and
walk away or you can
stay as a samuel 365 member and pay 95
pound a month you'll stick around i know
it
and then um work your strategy out take
action
implement build up your portfolio come
and join me on winners on a wednesday
and let's make it happen
phil thanks for your question sol
campbell's biggest fan
says you say you've bought lots of
properties using different strategies
yeah i said it because i have do you
have a reason for using a specific
strategy on a specific house or do you
just decide which strategy
you want to use randomly i don't know
why for a minute i thought i thought
this was going to be a hater but it's
not so i thought it was going to be like
well how do you prove this but um okay
good question
so what i think what you're saying is
you're saying um
you know like there's different
strategies to buy a house you can use
bridging loans to buy a house you can
buy them
um you can buy them on a lease option
agreement joint ventures you can raise
the finance
uh do it as a hmo take it on and control
it on a rent to rent you can maybe
package it and sell it instead of buying
it yourself
you're right there's a lot of different
strategies i've used them just about all
of
well all the ones i listed i've done all
of those a lot of times
so your question is do you just decide
randomly which one to use
the answer to that sol campbell's
biggest fan is it depends on what the
seller wants the reason there's
different options is because if you're
speaking to a seller that says
i need the money now i need to go fast
but i'm prepared to drop the price 30
percent
then you might think um okay he needs
the cash
i haven't got time to mess around and
get a mortgage this is a good deal
i haven't got the cash i'll just sell
this on to somebody
or maybe he'll say i don't need the
money now but i want a hundred percent
market value and you've got hmm
if he doesn't need the money now he
wants 100 market value maybe i could
offer him a lease option agreement and
buy it in five years time
but so it really depends basically i
haven't got a strategy people say samia
what's your strategy
i don't have a strategy i have multiple
strategies that i hold up my sleeve
i sit in front of motivated sellers and
say how can i help but depending on what
they tell me i'd pull that
strategy out and secure the property
that way
so i hope that helps great question
robert falan hi samuel i'm from scotland
i have been watching your videos for a
while now but all of your advice
would that work up here in scotland or
is it just down in england
also how would i go about starting my
own property business with no experience
and how would i find investors and and
so on if i did start
so robert yeah pretty much everything i
teach works in scotland i mean in
scotland the rules are slightly
different when you're buying your
property because if you put forward an
offer
and it's accepted it's almost like
auction terms you have to buy it you
can't pull out
so lease option agreements are probably
the only strategy this
doesn't quite work the same but
generally speaking yeah for sure they
work the same way
and in terms of how would you get
started i'd immerse yourself in
in in learning the skills i'd find three
or four people that are already
financially independent in property and
try and spend as much time with them as
possible
i take mad action and uh set a business
write a business plan
okay next we've got uttam
patel would you buy off plan property
ready in three years nope i wouldn't
jack what is the best thing to do as a
complete beginner in property what's the
best way to get knowledge quickly
um jack to get knowledge quickly i don't
know man
like if only someone
to get knowledge quickly if i need
someone to put together like
imagine if someone had put together like
a property investors
crash course where it was just like
condensed and you could just
fat 8 30. hey yeah you can do the
property university's crash course if
you want to get
all of the knowledge quickly and fast
track yourself to go from beginner to
someone that's almost like a
professional investor
go through the property investors crash
course it's a 195 pounds to do the
online course
it's amazing it's been very well put
together you can do it for free as a
samuel 365 member i'll leave all the
descriptions in the link
okay i fuss i'm contacting a bunch of
agents i'm hearing a lot of the time the
agents are saying sorry the house is
under offer
i don't know what i should be doing in
this scenario estate agents seem
uninterested in taking higher offers
this seems odd to me am i doing
something wrong
um okay and then mario underneath said
yes you are stop gezomping move on and
find another house
um yeah so basically at the moment
houses are selling really fast
okay we are literally houses are going
up and they're selling really quickly so
what's happening is you're ringing up an
estate agent and they're not being rude
to you
you're not doing anything wrong you're
just ringing up about a house and it's
just sold
and yeah i mean sometimes you
try buyers try and gump each other and
they go into bidding wars so the fact
that the agent is saying to you sorry
it's sold
and is sending you away is probably
actually a good thing because it's quite
annoying when bidding war start that's
why mario was like uh
stop the zombie people move on and i
think mario's probably right
i would probably move on maybe say to
the agent
okay that one's just sold no problem i
got the deposit together i'm ready to
move have you got anything else that's
about to come on the market which i can
get in there
quickly you know i mean it's a numbers
game
you know but right now properties are
selling so fast okay last question
luke mason hi samuel how would you
invest a hundred thousand pounds
how would you invest it if you had
limited free time i.e working long hours
it depends what i want to achieve if you
want to achieve cash flow you want to
achieve
wealth preservation are you going to
achieve capital appreciation
really depends on what you want to
achieve but if it was me i had a hundred
grand
i'd probably be putting it into i'd be
recycling it as far as i could go
i'm putting into a deal i'd be buying
prop a problem property
i'd fix the problem and then i'd pull
the money out tax free
on a refinance and then go again and
again again and build cash flow
and wealth at the same time i'd probably
do something like that and i'd do it
where would i do it maybe what i did in
birmingham birmingham is where
you know i've got most of my properties
i've got properties all over the country
but mostly in birmingham
midlands is a really really hot area i
like it i understand it
but i'd invest in where you know so
that's my advice
thank you for watching the video guys i
do a video every single day
and i hope it helps you if it does let
me know by subscribing to the channel
also drop a comment below let me know
your questions
smash the like button and i look forward
to seeing you next time thank you so
much i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
you